PROFESSOR: It was written about
Route 66, which used to
be the main highway between
Chicago, Illinois and Los
Angeles, California.
Very famous highway because
anybody who wanted to go
across country always took route
66 because it was the
shortest way to go.
And the question is, how do you
find the shortest path?
Not just any old path or a good
path, but how do you find
the very shortest path?
And that'll be the subject
that we're
going to discuss today.
But route 66, I lament its
passing, but it's been largely
replaced by the interstate
highway system that was
created by President
Eisenhower.
Guess why?
Let's see, maybe the
ROTC people know.
You know why Eisenhower
created the
interstate highway system?
Well, in public affairs, of
course, there's always a
distinction to be
made between the
explanation and the reason.
The explanation was--
AUDIENCE: To move weapons
across the country?
PROFESSOR: Well,
to move nuclear
weapons across the country.
Let's put it in, sightly,
more benign terms.
Eisenhower had observed that
the German army was able to
move its troops rapidly, even
though we bombed their
railroads into oblivion because
of their auto bond.
So Eisenhower conceived that if
there were ever an invasion
in the United States, we too
would want to be able to move
our forces around on
a highway system.
And consequence of that, we
have a pretty good highway
system and pretty awful
railroad system.
It's interesting.
I'm a beneficiary of that, in a
funny way, because I'm from
East Peoria, Illinois.
And I was surrounded by the
factors of Caterpillar Tractor
Company, which made all of the
tractors that built all of
those roads.
So my high school spent money
like water from that huge tax
base of all those factors.
Anyway, today we want to find
the very best path, instead of
just a good path.
And like the last time, we'll
deal with, both, an example
that we can set our program
to work on.
By the way, can you find the
shortest path between S and G?
Would you like to bet your
life on the shortest path
between S and G?
Probably, not.
With your eye, you can
find a good path.
But you can't find the
best possible path.
Today, what we're doing is
probably not modeling any
obvious property of what we
have inside our heads.
But being able to find the best
path is part of the skill
set that anybody who's had a
course artificial intelligence
would be expected to have.
So we're going to look at it,
even though it's not like many
of the things we do.
A model of something
that's, probably,
going on in your head.
So we're going to use, both,
this example from Cambridge
and our Blackboard example.
Let's see, we have to
caution ourselves.
Tanya, is search about maps?
No, it's about what?
Starts with a C. And the next
letter is H. And it ends up
being choice.
So we're talking about choice.
Not about maps.
Even though our examples are
drawn from maps because
they're convenient, they're
visual, and helps understand
the concepts behind the
algorithms I'm talking about.
So let's start off by looking
at our classroom example.
And I did something today that
I neglected to do last time.
And that's talk to you
about what I meant
by heuristic distance.
It's those pink lines that
I just drew on the map.
We're talking about the distance
as the crow would fly
between two places, even though
there's no road that
goes between those two places.
So in general, and we discussed
last time, it's best
to get yourself into a place
that's close, as the crow
flies, to your goal.
And of course, that's a
heuristic and it can get you
in trouble because it's
not always true.
It would appear that being at
node E is a good place to be
because it's not very far from
G. But in that particular case
designed to illustrate the
point, being close is,
actually, not a good thing
because it's a dead end.
But in general, it's a good
thing to be close.
And we talked last time about
hill climbing and beam search,
being close was the objective
of those kinds of searches.
And at one point, in a beam
search illustration, we had C,
B, A, and D. We had paths
terminating at all four of
those nodes as candidates for
the next round of search.
And we decided on the basis of
these airline distances to
keep D and B, and reject A and C
because they're further away
as the crow flies.
Now, I repeat this even though
many of you have had this
fixed already in your tutorials
because we're going
to need this concept of
heuristic distance today.
And I wanted to be sure that
that point has been clarified.
So now, with this smaller map I
imagine you can do, by eye,
a determination of what
the shortest path is.
What is it, Juana?
Can you help me out with that?
AUDIENCE: S, A, D, G.
PROFESSOR: S, A, D, G. And if
you add up those distances,
the distance is 11 along that
path that goes from S, first
to A, and then to D, and then
from D to G. So Juana asserts
that that is the best path.
And we're going to treat Juana
as an Oracle because we're
going to follow, in our initial
attempt to understand
these algorithms,
a very important
principle of problem solving.
And that is that, if you want
to solve a problem, the
easiest way is, usually, ask
somebody who knows the answer.
Or Google, which also, probably,
knows the answer.
So in this particular case,
we believe that
Juana knows the answer.
And she said that the shortest
path is S,A, D, G, and its
path length is 11.
But we don't trust her because
we're applying to the same
medical school and she may
be trying to screw us.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So we're going to
be very cautious about
accepting her answer until we've
checked it to make sure
that she hasn't attempted
to delude us.
So how do we go about
doing that?
Well, one way to do that is to
check to be sure that all
other possible paths that we
could develop end up being,
for sure, longer than the one
that Juana has told us about.
So she's told us about S, A, D,
G. And it has a total path
length of 11.
And now what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to develop
the rest of this tree-like
diagram.
But what I'm going to do is,
I'm not going to do it in a
British Museum or random way.
What I'm going to do is, I'm
going to look at the choice
that corresponds the shortest
path that can be extended.
So the shortest path that
can be extended is
this one right here.
The one that just has the
starting node in it.
And I could have gone this other
way to B. And if I go
that other way to B, then
the path length along
that side is 5.
And likewise, if I look at the
path that terminates in A,
that has a path length of 3.
So now I've got two choices.
A and B. I've got choices
that extend
beyond those two places.
So I'm always going to
extend the one that
has the shorter length.
So in this case, that would be
the path that goes from S to
A.
So if I from S to A, I don't
have to go to D. I can also go
to B. And if I go to B, then the
accumulated path length is
S, A, B. That's 7.
And know that we're talking now
about the path, like the
accumulated path length, that
we've traveled so far.
Last time we were talking
a lot about
distances to the goal.
Heuristic estimates of how
far we are from the goal.
Now we're doing exactly
the opposite.
We're not considering how
far we've got to go.
We're only thinking about how
far we've gone so far.
So now, repeating these
steps again.
I've got 7 and 5.
So I'll go over and consider
the choices that go through
the B node on the path S, B. And
that gives me S, B, A and
S, B, C. And what are
those path lengths?
Well, let's see.
S, B, A would be 9.
And S, B,C would be 9.
And now the shortest path
is this one over here.
So I extend that.
I go S, A, B. S, A, B. The only
place I can go is C. That
adds another 4.
So that's 11.
And what do I know
about that path?
I don't have to take that
any further, right?
Because the path length, since
I've gone on that path
already, is equal to the path
length that Juana has told me
gets me to the goal.
So it'll be foolhardy to carry
on because, presuming that
these lengths are all
non-negative, I
can't do any better.
And I can't even do as well,
unless I've got a length that
has 0 length.
So now that I have that idea,
I can quickly finish up by
saying, well, let me consider
these two paths.
S, B, A can only go to D. And
if I go to D, that adds 3.
9 plus 3 is 12.
Nothing else can happen there
because that's 12 and I've got
a path of a goal that's 11.
C, I can only go to E. It's a
dead-end but I don't have to
think about that because I
know that the accumulated
distance along this
path is 6 plus 9.
That's 15.
So all of these need not be
extended any further because
their length, accumulated so
far, is equal to or less than
a length of a goal.
So I've checked the Oracle.
And although we're applying to
the same medical school, Juana
has told me the truth.
So now, unfortunately, Juana's
not always around.
And I don't always
have an Oracle.
So I'm going to have to have
some way of finding the
shortest path without
that Oracle
that I can check against.
Let's see.
What can I do?
Maybe I can do the same
thing I just did.
Always extend the shortest path
so far and hope that I
run into the goal
at some point.
And then I have to ask myself
the question how much extra
work did I need to do when
I don't have the Oracle?
Let's just try it and
see what happens.
You don't have that
path to start.
So I just have S. This
distance is 0.
I can go either to A or B.
If I go to A, I've got
a distance of 3.
Here, I've got a
distance of 5.
I'll extend the path that goes
S, A. That can either got to B
or D. Going to B or D
gives me 7 that way.
S, A, D gives me 6.
So looking across all of these
and extending the shortest
path so far takes me back over
to S, B. So I extend those.
S, B takes me to A or C.
And those, in turn, have
total accumulated path
lengths of 9 and 9.
Now the shortest one is S, A,
D. You see the pattern.
Now let's see.
I haven't found the goal yet.
So I can ask myself the question
is any of the work
that I've done so far wasted?
No because all of the paths
that I've got so far are
shorter than the path of the
goal because the goal
hasn't shown up.
So when I do my oracle checking
after I found the
goal, none of that work's
going to be wasted.
So in the end, I don't,
actually, need the Oracle.
I could just develop this
graph by extending the
shortest path, so far,
until I hit the goal.
And then, perhaps, do a little
remaining checking to make
sure that all the other paths
extend with a length that's
greater than the path
of the goal.
So if those words are confusing,
let's carry on with
the algorithm, and I think
it'll be clearer.
So let's see.
We've got the 7,
6, and two 9s.
We're going to extend
the one that's 6.
That gets this to the goal.
Boom, we've got it.
And we've got a path
length of 11.
Note, though, we can't quit
because we have to be sure
that all other paths
are longer than 11.
So now we have to carry on with
the same algorithm that
we started with.
The Oracle checking algorithm.
And when we do that, we look
for this shortest path, so
far, that has not
been extended.
That's B, S, A, B. That
goes to C. That's 11.
So we're done there.
A goes to D. That adds 3.
That's 12.
C goes to E. That adds 6.
That's 15.
And sure enough, we're done.
OK?
Elliot?
AUDIENCE: Does it know that
there's know that there isn't
a chance that you could have a
zero distance extension from
the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: The question is, does
it know that there's no
zero distance length
that's coming up.
That's an implementation
detail.
This guarantees you'll find a
path that's as short as any
that you can possibly find.
But there might be others if
they're zero-length lengths.
As long as they're non-negative
lengths, we're safe.
We've got a shortest path.
So that was easy.
And now we can repeat the
exercise with our more
complicated map of Cambridge.
First of all, let's do depth
first just to recall what that
looks like.
That is, certainly,
not a short path.
So let's try this idea, which,
by the way, bares the label
branch inbound.
Let's try branch inbound
on the same map.
And there it goes.
Each of those little flickers
is trying another path.
So you can see it's working
it's guts out to find the
shortest path.
It's almost there but it's
almost a pathological case.
Or it's almost doing
British Museum.
There it's finally found
the shortest path.
Now there are some things
we can ask about that.
But first of all, before I ask
anything about it, I'd like to
get the flow chart up on the
board because we're going to
decorate that flow chart,
a little bit, as we go.
So the first thing we do
is initialize queue.
Then we're going to test first
path on the queue.
Then we might be happy because
we might be done.
We might have a shortest
path to the goal.
Actually, that's not
quite true, is it?
We can't really quit until
every other path is it.
Well, that's interesting.
If the first element on the
queue gets us all the way to
the goal, and we sorted our
queue by path length, are we
through as soon as that first
element on the queue gets us
to the goal?
Yeah because every other
path must have been
sorted beyond it.
And therefore, it can't offer us
a shorter path to the goal.
So if the first path is a path
to the goal we're done.
Alas, it usually isn't.
So we'll extend first path.
We're going to put all those
extensions back on the queue,
and then we're going
to sort them.
So that's, pretty much, the
same as we did last time.
We're always going to put the
elements back on the queue.
We're going to look at the first
element the queue and
see if it's a winner.
If it is we're done.
If it's not, we're going
to extend it.
And then go back in here
and try again.
Well, sort of.
But we noted that this did a
awful lot of work because if
we look at those statistics
up there, it put 1,354
paths onto the queue.
That's the N queueing part.
And then it extended 835,000
paths that had come to the
front of the queue.
Now I'd like to give you an
aside because it's easy to get
confused about N queueing
and extending.
In all of the searches we did
last time, it would have been
perfectly reasonable to keep a
list of all the paths that we
had put onto the queue.
An N queueing list.
And never add a path to our
queue if it terminates in a
node that some other path
terminate in that has already
gone to the queue.
What I said last time was let
us keep track of the things
that have been extended and
not extend them again.
So you can either keep track
of the nodes that have been
extended and not extend
them again.
Or look at the paths with nodes
that terminate, and
blah, blah, blah and been put on
the queue, the queued ones.
And not put things back
on the queue again.
And I think, last time, I may
have put a column in there
that said N queued.
It should have been extended.
Even though N queued worked last
time, only extended works
this time because we want to
be sure that anything we
extend is a short path.
So the N queued idea doesn't
work, at all, for these
optimal paths.
So now I want to come back over
here off the side bar and
say that we're keeping track
of all of the nodes, all of
the paths that end in nodes
unless they have already been
extended beyond that
particular place.
So we need to decorate our
algorithm here and say test
first path and extend
the first path
if not already extended.
Because you can see that in the
example I had, so far, we
did that same silliness that
we talked about last time.
We extended paths that
went through A more
than once, like so.
Would it ever make sense
to extend this path?
No because we've already
extended a path that got there
with less distance.
Will it ever make sense
to extend this path?
No because we've already
extended another path that
gets to be by a shorter
distance.
So if we keep an extended
list, we can add that to
branch inbound to
our advantage.
So let's see how that would work
on the classroom example.
And then we'll do Cambridge.
So this is bridge inbound,
plus an extended list.
And I do mean extended.
Not in the N queued list.
N queued list won't work here.
So let's see, I start off the
same way as I did before.
S goes to either A or B.
That's a length of 3.
That's a length of 5.
So I extend A. That goes to
either B or D. But B is as if
it wasn't there at all.
Oh, sorry.
Hang on.
B goes there.
And those path lengths
are 7 and 6.
And now I look around on the
board, and I say what is the
shortest path so far?
And it's B. So I extend that
to get to A and C with path
lengths of 9 and 9.
And what's the shortest
one next?
It's D. And that goes to G.
And the path length is 11.
And what's the shortest
one on the board?
The one that has to
be extended next.
That's this one that gets to B.
But I've already extended a
path that get to B. So I don't,
actually, do that extension.
So I've saved some work.
But I've got to go over here
and do these two now.
But wait.
I've already extended B. I've
already extended A, so I don't
have to do that one either.
The only one I have to do is
the one that goes to C. And
that those then to E with
a path length of 15.
And I'm done.
So if you compare this one with
a previous one, you can
see that there might be vast
areas of this tree that are
pruned away and don't have
to be examined all.
So now, just for the sake of
illustrating that, I would
like to keep track of just
one of those statistics.
The number of extensions.
So for this particular example,
case one, the number
of extensions was 835.
Why don't you see if you can
guess to yourself what it
would be if I use this concept
of an extended list.
See, I'm not going to extend
anything I've already extended
because it's guaranteed to have
a longer path length then
something that already got
to that same place.
So it makes no sense to do it.
So let me change the type to
branch-and-bound with an
extended list.
I'm going to turn the speed
down a little bit so
we can watch it.
It might take the rest
of the hour.
Who knows?
Still doing a lot of work.
Still examining a
lot of paths.
Well, look at that.
Instead of 835 extensions
it only did 38.
So that's a pretty substantial
savings.
And you would never not
want to do that.
So note that that's a layering
on top of branching out.
That's not a different
algorithm.
It's an adjustment improvement
to the algorithm, and it makes
it more efficient.
So this whole thing is
based on what I call
the dead horse principle.
As soon as we figure out that
a path that goes to a
particular place can't possibly
be the winning path,
we get rid of it, and don't
bother extending it.
It's a dead horse principle.
But if we look at this example,
what's the shortest
possible length of a
path that's already
gone from S to B?
What do you think, Tanya?
Well, first of all, it can't be
less than 5 because we've
already gone that distance.
So when I say what's the
shortest length of any path
that there could possibly be
that goes from S to D. We know
it's at least 5.
But can we say something
more about it?
Especially, when we look at
these airline distances, and
note that this airline distance
is 6, and that's a
little more than 7, and that's
a little more than 7.
So what do you think?
So it's gone from S to B, and
the question is what's the
shortest path that could
possibly be that had started
out going from S to B?
11 right?
Because we can't have a path
that's shorter than the
airline distance.
If there were a straight line
road from A to G, its length
would be 6.
But there isn't.
So that gives us a lower bound
on the distance that we have
along that path.
So we're using the accumulated
distance, plus the airline
distance, to give us a lower
bound on the path that we've
started off on that
goes from S to B.
Once again, let's solidify a
little bit by simulating the
search and seeing how
it turns out.
Not just I did last time, I'm
going to forget that I've got
an extended list.
I don't want to carry both of
those things around with me at
the same time.
So forget that we've got
an extended list.
We'll bring all those back
together a little later.
So we're going to forget
what we just did there.
And instead we're just going
to use this concept of an
airline distance and
see what happens.
As before we start with
a starting node.
We have two choices as always.
We can go to A or B. And the
accumulated distance, if we go
to A, is 3.
And then accumulated distance
if we go to B is 5.
But now we're going to add
in the airline distances.
So the airline distance from A
to G is a little more than 7,
which is 10 plus.
The airline distance from
B to G is exactly 6.
So that gives us 11.
And following the procedure
we've all been using already
so far, we're going to extend
the path that seems to have
the shortest potential.
Now it's the shortest potential
distance S to G. So
that must be this one here.
So from A we can go to B
or D. The accumulated
distance S, A, B, is 7.
The airline distance is 6,
so that's equal to 11.
Standard arithmetic 13.
The distance S, A, D. That is
6 plus a little more than 7.
So what's the accumulated
distance?
S, A, D is 3 plus 3 is 6.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: The airline distance
from D would be 5.
PROFESSOR: Would be 5, right.
So airline distance, in this
case, is the same as the
actual distance.
So the accumulated
distance is 6.
The actual distance is 5.
So that's equal to 11.
So now I've got two
11's on the board.
And simulating what we'd ask
you do on a quiz, we don't
know which of those is
going to be better.
They've got a tie score.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to choose the one
that's lexically least.
So B comes before D. So we'll
expand B. And that can go to
either A or C. And we have to
calculate the best possible
distance that goes along
those paths.
The accumulated distance
S, B, A. S, B, A is 9.
So that's 9 plus 7 plus.
That's 16 plus.
This has an accumulated
lead of distance of 9.
Also plus 7 plus.
Also 16 plus.
Well, now let's see.
Things are shaping up pretty
well because this one has the
lowest score so far.
We extend that to
G. And now the
accumulated distance is 11.
The airline distance
is 0, so that's 11.
And that's smaller than
everybody else.
So we've got.
So now compare this one with
our branch inbound graph.
And you see, once again, we've
done considerably less work.
And that, in many practical
cases, means that instead of
taking more than the remaining
lifetime of the universe to
complete the calculation, it can
happen in a few seconds.
But let's see how it works
on the example.
So I'm not going to use
the extended list.
I'm just going to use this idea
of using a lower bound on
the distance remaining,
the airline distance,
and see what happens.
So this time, the number
of extensions is 70.
So it didn't do quite as well
as working alone as the
extended list did
working alone.
So we immediately conclude that
the extended list is more
useful than using one of these
lower bound heuristics.
By the way, this is called
an admissible heuristic.
If the heuristic estimate is
guaranteed to be less than the
actual distance, that's called
an admissible heuristic.
Admissible because you can use
it for this kind of purpose.
So it looks like the day
extended list is a more useful
idea than the admissible idea.
Right?
What do you think about
that, Brett?
Am I hacking?
Am I joking?
AUDIENCE: I think you're
judging prematurely.
PROFESSOR: Why am I judging
prematurely?
What do you think it
might depend on?
AUDIENCE: The fact that we're
using extensions and the
extended list pretty much
guarantees you can only extend
each node once.
PROFESSOR: Well, Brett has sad
something unintelligible that
I can't think how to repeat.
What he meant to say,
though, was that--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: --in these cases,
it almost always depends on
the problem itself.
If you change the problem, you
may get a different result.
So why don't we change the
problem and see if we get a
different result?
So instead of starting on the
extreme left, let's start in
the middle and see
what happens.
So I'll readjust my starting
position to be right there.
Oops, that's the wrong
adjustment.
And we might as well start
by getting our baseline
branch-and-bound without
anything.
And for that one, maybe, we'll
speed it up a little bit.
So that gives us
57 extensions.
It's an easier problem.
So let's try it with the
admissible heuristic.
That went too fast.
Wow, still pretty fast.
Six extensions.
What do you think this
number's going to be?
Closer to six or closer to 57?
Better than six?
Worse than six?
Well, let's think.
What we're going to do is we're
going to just not repeat
any movements through
the same node again.
But it's not going to
do something very
important for us.
It's not going to keep us out
of the left side because it
has no idea of the remaining
airline distance to the goal.
So let's see if that's
true It sure is.
Look at that.
It is, foolishly, spending
a lot of its' time doing
something we would never do.
Namely, looking over there
on the left side.
So this time, the number
of extensions is 35.
So in case two, the admissible
heuristic
does very much better.
In case one, the extension
thing does much better.
But wait a minute, would we ever
not want to use both at
the same time?
We wouldn't want to use just
one of these, right?
They both have the possibility
of doing us a lot of good.
So maybe if we put them in
harness together, we'll get
something that's even better.
And when we do that--
see here, the extended list
is a layer on top
of branch and bound.
The admissible heuristic
is another layer on top
of branch and bound.
If we put those together, we get
something called A star.
So A star is just branch and
bound, plus an extended list,
plus and admissible heuristic.
So let's go back to our original
problem and try A
star on that.
We're running this at a pretty
slow speed because we're
expecting it to be a lot more
efficient than the original
branch and bound.
And sure enough it is.
The number of extensions
is 27.
So look at that.
A lot better than either of
those working independently.
Now I can stick the thing in
the center and see what
happens then.
So in this particular case,
the extended list didn't,
actually, help us because our
admissible heuristic was
channeling us so tightly
toward the
goal it didn't matter.
So it all depends on the nature
of the space that
you're trying to explore.
By the way, you know how
the whole works, right?
So what you want to do is
you want to extend the
first path and sort.
But not just by accumulated
distance.
Sort by accumulated distance
plus admissible heuristic.
But what are the
theoreticians?
You must be complaining.
Sort's expensive.
Do we actually need to sort?
No, we don't actually
need to sort.
What do we to do?
AUDIENCE: We just need to keep
track of what's the minimum.
PROFESSOR: We just need
to keep track
of what's the minimum.
So we don't need to, actually,
do that sort.
That's an unnecessary
computation.
So instead, we can test, not
the first path but the
shortest path.
And now you have it.
Now you have the whole
of A star.
And now you can go home, but I
don't think you should because
I'm about to show you that this
idea of admissibility,
actually, leads to certain screw
cases that we're very
fond of asking about on exams.
So it turns out that the
admissible heuristic, in
certain circumstances, could
get you into trouble.
It doesn't look like it could
because, logically, nothing
I've said seems strange
or questionable.
But that's because I've been
working with a map.
And it turns out that if you
work with a map then
admissibility is a perfectly
sound way of
doing an optimal search.
But, Travis, is search
just about maps?
No, search is not
just about maps.
So we may have non-Euclidean
arrangements that will cause
us trouble.
So I'd like to illustrate that
with the following example.
It's not going to be a large
map or a large graph.
S, then go up here to A or
down here to B. Then they
merge at C. And then they go
out here to the goal, G.
And the actual distances
are 1, 1, 1, and 10.
And over here, we'll
make that 100.
So it's a kind of oddly
constructed map, but it's
there because we need a
pathological case to
illustrate the idea.
Now that's the actual
distances.
And if we did branch and down
with an extended list,
everything would
work just fine.
But we're not.
We're going to use an admissible
heuristic.
And we're going to say that
this guy has an estimated
distance to the goal of 100.
This guy is 0.
And this guy is 0.
Now, 0 is always an
underestimate of the actual
distance to the goal, right?
So I'm always free to use 0.
Is that 100 OK?
Yeah because the actual
distances is 101, so it's less
than that the actual distance.
So it's OK as an admissible
heuristic.
So these numbers that I put up
here, together, constitute an
admissible heuristic set of
estimates to the goal.
So now, let's just simulate A
star and see what happens.
So first of all, you start with
S, and that can either go
to A or B. The actual distance
is 1 plus an estimate on the
remaining distance.
That gives us 100 plus 100.
That's equal to 101.
If we go to B instead, the
actual distance is 1 plus the
heuristic's distance is 0,
so that's equal to 1.
OK, good.
So now we know that we
always extend the
shortest path so far.
Did I goof this, or are
you asking a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, when I say
actual, it's the actual
distance that you've traveled.
AUDIENCE: But that's
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So wait a second.
If I go from S to A,
the actual distance
I've traveled is 1.
AUDIENCE: I meant like,
does the map--
PROFESSOR: So now I'm taking
the sum of the actual
distance, plus the estimated
distance to go.
AUDIENCE: All right.
I'm just wondering if the
original map has to be
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: See this
is not a map.
She was asking if the map has to
be geometrically accurate.
See, this could be a model of
something that's not a map.
And so, I'm free to put any
numbers on those links that I
want, including estimates, as
long as they're underestimates
of the distance along
the lengths.
So this tells me that my
estimated distance
here, so far, is 1.
So I'll, surely, go down here
to C. And if I go to C, then
my accumulated distance is 11.
And my estimate of the remaining
distance is 0.
So that's a total of 11.
So now I'm following my
heuristic again and saying
what's the shortest path on
a base of the accumulated
distance plus the estimated
distance?
Here, the accumulated
distance plus the
estimated distance is 101.
Here, it's only 11.
So plainly, I extend this guy.
And that gets me to the goal.
And the total accumulated
distance is now 111 plus 0
equals 111.
And that's not the shortest
path, but wait.
I still have to do my
checking, right?
I have to extend A. I when I
extend A, I get to B. And now,
when I get to B that
way, my accumulated
distance is 2 plus my--
oh, sorry.
S, A, C.
My accumulate distance it 2.
My estimated distance is 0,
so that's equal to 2.
So I'm OK because I'm still
going to extend
to this guy, right?
Wrong.
I've already extended
that guy.
So I'm hosed.
I won't find the shortest
path because I'm
going to stop there.
And I'm going to stop there
because this is an admissible
heuristic and that's not good
enough unless it's a map.
It's not good enough for this
particular case because this
is not geometric.
This cannot be done as
a map on a plane.
So that's a situation where what
I've talked to you about,
so far, works with
branch-and-bound.
Works with branch-and -bound
plus an extended list.
But doesn't work when we added
an admissible heuristic.
So if we're going to do this in
general, we need something
stronger than admissibility,
which works only on maps.
And so the flourish that I'll
tell you about here in the
last few seconds of today's
lecture is to add a refinement
as follows.
So far, we've got
admissibility.
And if we want to write this
down in a kind of mathematical
notation, we could say that
it's admissible if the
estimated distance between any
node X and the goal is less
than or equal to the
actual distance
between X and the goal.
That's the definition
of admissible.
As long as heuristic does
that it's admissible.
And A star works
if it's a map.
But for that kind of situation
where it's not a map we need a
stronger condition, which
is called consistency.
And what that says is that the
distance between X and the
goal minus the distance between
some other node in the
goal, Y. Take the absolute
value of that.
That has to be less than or
equal to the actual distance
between X and Y.
So this heuristic satisfy the
consistency condition?
Well, let's see.
Here the guess is 100.
Here it's 0.
So the absolute difference
is 100.
But the actual distance
is only 2.
So it satisfies admissibility,
but it doesn't satisfy
consistency.
And it doesn't work.
So you can almost be guaranteed
we'll give you a
situation where if you
use an admissible
heuristic you'll lose.
And if you use a consistent
heuristic, you'll still win.
So how can we bring this
back into the fold?
Well, we can't use
that heuristic.
It's no good.
But if this heuristic estimate
of the goal were 2, then we'd
be OK because then it would
still be admissible.
But it would also
be consistent.
So the bottom line is that you
now know something you didn't
know when you started out
two lectures ago.
You now know how MapQuest and
all of its' descendents work.
Now you can find an optimal
path, as well as a
heuristically good path.
You see that if you don't do
anything other than branch and
bound it can be extremely
expensive.
And you can even invent
pathological cases where it's
exponential and the distance
to the goal.
So because it can be so
computationally horrible, you
want to use every advantage
you can, which, generally,
involves using an
extended list.
As well as--
no laptops, please.
It still holds.
No smoking, no drinking,
and no laptops.
So you're going to use all
the muscles you can.
And those muscles include using
an extended list and an
admissible or consistent
heuristic, depending on the
circumstances.
And so, I think we'll conclude
there since our time is up.
And Elliot, you can ask a
question after class.
Why don't you come up
and ask it now?